hi everyone this on really good to be
here my name is Thiago and this talk is
gonna be really different from every
other talk here because I'm not a react
developer in fact I'm not a software
developer at all I've never written one
well maybe besides some basic HTML I've
never written code what I do is I'm a
Productivity anthropologist I embed
myself in communities the design
community the tech startup community and
most recently that's what the software
development community and I learn how
you do things I study you like an
anthropologist and then I take the ways
that you do things the the the methods
that you have of getting things done and
I translate them for normal people I
turned that into books blog posts and
online courses teaching normal people
how to be as productive as software
developers and designers and startups I
want to start off ok I want to start off
talking about flow also known as the
experience of flow or the psychology of
flow kind of kills my momentum so this
was coined by Csikszentmihalyi who
defined it as a mental state of
operation in which a person performing
an activity is fully immersed in a
feeling of energized focus full
involvement and enjoyment in the process
of the activity you know what I'm
talking about it's when you get so deep
into a book that the characters on the
page seem more real than the world
around you or or when you're you're
playing a sport that you're actually
good at and your thoughts and your
actions seem to fuse into one and you
lose all self-criticism
all self-awareness as you get into the
flow of the sport or obviously when you
are coding when you're deep in the
bowels of writing your program and all
of the information all of the the
problem is that your mental
your tips you know exactly everything
you need to solve the problem and I
think the one of the issues with how we
talk about flow is we talk about it like
it's a mystical experience like it's a
quasi-religious like that god of flow
descends upon us when actually the
science of flow which is called
transient hypofrontality in the
literature is very well understood okay
it's just a sequence of neuro chemicals
norepinephrine Titans focus dopamine
improves pattern recognition an end of
mead improves lateral thinking nitric
oxide suppresses the stress response so
that relief you feel as you really get
into it and it's nitric oxide flooding
your bloodstream and of course
endorphins which is the the reward the
payoff at the end gives you that sense
of inner peace and tranquility and the
thing I want to point out about flow is
that it represents the in the
intersection of positive experience
performance and learning rightful this
is why Holy Grail is the holy [ __ ] flow
is the holy grail of productivity right
you don't have to choose just one of
these or just two you get three when
you're in that state of flow now
probably up until now no surprise right
I don't have to tell you how great flow
is I don't have to tell you yeah you
should get into flow but now I'm going
to get a bit controversial okay because
I think the typical way that people try
to create flow things such as blocking
avoiding interruptions and distractions
in other words people long long
uninterrupted stretches of focus time
single tasking timeboxing back-to-back
Sprint's and managing a lot of work and
process in your head
these are outdated this is an old
paradigm that's not going to continue
into the future
all of these ways of working which are
very well known
you know productivity tips and
approaches to productivity are all what
I call heavy lips okay a heavy lift is
what it sounds like it's this big long
hard slog of work of you just getting
through this massive amount of work in
one big push okay now there are times
and places for heavy lips definitely
alright sometimes the problem cannot be
just be composed the the the module
cannot be decomposed you have to take on
the whole thing
but I think if you think that the only
way to produce value the only way to get
into flow is a heavy lift you're gonna
be in trouble you're gonna be in trouble
because heavy lips are socially
isolating they take you away from people
they're very hard on your body and your
mind it's one thing to do a heavy lift
every day in your 20s weight into the
year in your 30s or 40s okay kind of at
the level of the group or the level of
the organization heavy lifts or this
idea that the developer is supposed to
be heads down in their little box just
laboring on the problem it actually
takes developers out of positions of
influence and leadership if you haven't
seen the book developer hegemony by Eric
Dietrich I really recommend it he talks
about some of the political and social
implications of this this situation I
think heavy lifts actually have the
effect on businesses of taking
developers away from the business side
away from the human side away from the
leadership side where your expertise
your logical way of thinking your
practicality is so so needed more than
ever okay I think heavy lifts are not
the only way to get things done and it's
interesting when you look at the the
science the research on what produces
flow there's internal triggers clear
goals immediate feedback and a challenge
to skill ratio where it's hard enough to
be challenging so you don't get bored
but not so difficult that you give up
right so a certain challenge to skill
ratio
and there's external triggers the
presence of risk there has to be some
risk deep embodiment and a rich
environment okay there's nothing in here
if you'll notice about any span of time
there's no research as far as I know and
if you find anything please send it to
me there is no indication that you need
a huge block of time to get into flow
there just as not I think that's a
legacy of an old way of working where we
had a huge block of time called an
eight-hour workday and so we assumed an
eight-hour block of time was necessary
okay and here's the thing I know that
you've experienced this right I know
you've experienced many times where you
sat down and for some reason the
environment the people you're working
with the nature of the problem the tools
you have you just drop straight into
flow right you don't need this long
setup phase you don't need six hours of
focus right what I'm saying is some of
those factors can be planned because
flow is an actual neurochemical
phenomenon we can plan it we can
encourage it we can design for it and to
kind of get a little more specific what
I want to do so my mission basically is
to do for knowledge work what has been
done for software development over the
past few decades right so I want to make
knowledge work and I don't mean just one
activity all knowledge work stateful
encapsulated reusable and composable
okay and at this point I'm gonna ask you
to sort of maybe take off your software
developer hat and think of yourself for
just the next 20 minutes as a knowledge
worker okay so you do coding coding is
knowledge work right but there are so
many I don't care if you're the most
specialized focused developer in the
world there's so many activities that
you do right you have conversations you
have meetings you plan you brainstorm
you make drawings you learn you read
things you watch videos I mean the job
of being a software developer is this
this incredible variety of different
types of knowledge work different ways
of working with information so think of
yourself
for now just as an as an overall
knowledge worker and as I think you well
know knowledge work today is like a big
blob just think of knowledge workers all
around the world most of them they sit
down and their work has no parts it has
no clear edges so in order to make any
progress they have to load up the whole
blob into their head just to be able to
do one thing right just like programming
used to be right programming used to be
the effort of a genius who would load up
the whole program into their mind and
now you have a different way of working
with software which is in parts and
modules and components that's what I
want to do for knowledge work so let's
look at these one at a time what would
it look like what does it even mean for
knowledge work to be stateful and as I
was saying I want you to think about so
there's a misconception that your work
is made up of tasks right I'm gonna ask
you show me your work and you point to
your to-do list I think that's a
misconception your to-do list is not
your work right it refers to your work
it points to your work all right if I
destroyed your to-do list
with all your work be destroyed and no
your work is actually made up of content
it's like producing content sure there's
the codebase there's documentation but
I'm talking about way more than that
think of everything you create along the
way every all the intermediate working
process right you might have specs you
might have wireframes user stories you
might have notes on your daily stand-ups
or your sprint retrospective going even
further back you might have drawings
architectural diagrams flowcharts going
even further back the books he read the
podcasts you listen to the drawing on
the back of a napkin in a restaurant who
knows what it is right this is the
content that you're producing in your
work and this is what I think is the
real value of knowledge work right this
intermediate work that usually gets used
and then kind of just thrown aside we
don't really keep track of it it's just
kind of oh that's just
intermediate work
so no talk on productivity would be
complete without five steps right there
must be five steps so the last part of
my talk is gonna be you know the five
weird tricks for you to make your your
work not just your software development
work stateful encapsulated reusable and
composable step one is you got to
collect it okay we've been for for many
years on this decentralization trend
right there's an app for everything
every little thing you want to do
there's an app but what I think that
hides from us is the fact that you are
even if you don't think so you're
producing huge amounts of content huge
and I teach a course on this where I
lead people through this process and I'm
just time and time again I'm amazed that
people once they collect all of their
content together like photos web pages
different snippets of text handwritten
notes book notes voice memos they're
shocked how much is there right they're
completely shocked how much incredible
content they produced so you got to get
it all in one place right it's not it's
no good you won't be able to make
connections between things to see what
relates to what if they're all spread
out in a million different tools what
would it make what would it look like to
make knowledge working capsulated so
once you've collected all this
information you have to break it up into
small packets with clean edges okay this
is I think the big flaw in current
knowledge management approaches and if
you look at wiki's you look at knowledge
bases you look at that one Google Doc at
your work we're like all of the user
research is stored and just like loading
up that Google Doc takes like five
minutes right there's no clean edges
it's not packets it's more like streams
really big streams where you don't know
where it begins you don't know where it
ends it's difficult to extract one
little section out and combine it with
something else it's difficult to point
someone directly to one point in the
document all right I think we have to
move to a paradigm that is much closer
to
Hackett's right just like the internet
moved from from basically phone lines to
DSL moved from streams of audio data to
packets packet switching networks we
need to do the same for knowledge work
and that involves breaking it up into
little pieces and I'll say more about
that in a second and there's a lot of
different tools you could use you know
you could use cloud storage tools you
can use repositories you can use wiki's
all these things but there's one
category of tools that I've found is
really ideally suited for this which is
note-taking apps I know it's not very
sexy it's not very cool and trendy but
apps like Evernote which is which is the
one I use and recommend but also bare
simple note OneNote and Google keep most
people don't even know that Google has a
note-taking app right I think are
ideally suited for this because the best
paradigm for managing our content as
knowledge workers as notes right no it's
not documents not files not folders
notes which are personal informal quick
and dirty they're open-ended and never
finished you have low expectations you
don't have to make them super perfect
super you know perfectly formatted
perfectly structured and a mix diverse
types of media right even when notes
were on paper you can imagine making a
drawing making a sketch pasting in a
photo writing something if it's digital
putting a video notes very naturally
include all different types of media all
of this while maintaining one discrete
unit which is the note write a note what
does it look like to make knowledge work
reusable so once you have these modules
you can't go oh I have lots of content
module so it's great you have to give
them clean interfaces right Legos only
work because they're like measure down
to the micro millimeter and any two
Legos in the world will fit together
right very clean interfaces for content
what this looks like is metadata and
these are just examples this can take
many different forms these are more
specific to text but there's different
metadata for images for videos
you know everything from informative
titles naming conventions thematic tags
summaries comments and annotations
formatting links and images right each
one of these modules needs to be
described in a way that you can quickly
get the gist of it so you can see
whether you want to combine it with
other modules of content step four is to
organize right until we have true
artificial intelligence it's not going
to be enough to just dump all of this
content into one big folder and say I'll
search for a later I don't think I don't
think we're there yet and what I find
time and time again is you don't have to
that word organized like Oh organize
like is that really adding value is that
really necessary what I find time and
time and time again is when people are
starting a project and they want to know
do I have something existing that I
could use for this they asked two
questions they asked what have I done
like this before and they say what do I
know on this topic just two simple
questions which implies there's a very
simple organizational scheme you can use
in organizing york your work in process
content which is by project and my topic
and finally composable this is probably
the thing you least thought you would
hear to developer conference but I think
and it's also the most ambiguous part
right it really depends the create this
is essentially the creative process
really depends if you're a coder if
you're an artist if you're a writer if
you're a musician but I think the way to
get better at compose ability to make
our work more composable is to practice
composing you can do a few next like
four
okay this can include seen actually
practicing training getting good at
swishing contexts getting feedback from
your colleagues from outside
collaborators from customers interviews
user interviews interviews of others it
includes writing write tweet storms
which is my personal favorite if you
follow me on Twitter get ready for some
really long tweet storms I'm sorry
taking good notes writing write writing
is this process of externalizing your
thoughts and it helps clarify your
entire creative process to get that
writing published drawing right visual
thinking explaining things making
diagrams making abstract ideas more
tangible performing okay now it starts
to get performing right but I think when
you take that step to get on a stage to
really stand in front of people and say
I know what I'm talking about your
knowledge what you know your performance
your productivity takes on a whole new
level because you're forced to stand for
something so it could include I mean
nothing that crazy speaking at an event
speaking at a meet-up or recording a
video don't even have to get in front of
people
we have YouTube and periscope and
Twitter and all these things producing
right actually publishing releasing
early and releasing often to the outside
work to the outside world summarizing or
condensing someone else's ideas
interpreting them or critiquing them or
Trant even just translating from one
medium to another and finally selling
right when you put yourself and your
work on the line to sell them and I mean
selling for money but also selling your
ideas teaching or selling your projects
which is collaborating right this kind
of a spectrum from from like more
private to more public less engaged to
more engaged right this is what I think
composability looks like in the broader
world of knowledge work and it's
something most knowledge workers do not
do right yeah we have blogs social media
is pushing everyone in this direction
but what would it look like if we were
all
constantly pushing out valuable work to
help others learn to help others advance
to clarify our own thinking the thinking
of others I think the world would look
very different and I think the benefits
this would bring to knowledge work are
some of the same benefits that you've
experienced over the last years in
software development abstraction right
imagine if kind of general knowledge
work had abstraction you could separate
content from presentation flexibility
lay binding right what if instead of
creating everything from scratch from
zero upfront knowledge workers around
the world could just create modules
spend all of their time producing and
documenting modules and then right when
the problem arose right at the point
where a solution is needed they could
just snap together different modules of
content that they've already produced
reusability like I said instead of
starting from scratch instead of
starting from zero you could basically
bootstrap projects just like like
bootstrap and other front-end frameworks
where you have like 80% of the the basic
set up for you and you just build on top
of that a single source of truth instead
of you know duplicate duplicate
duplicate like having 16 versions of
every single document and then you
upload it on box and no one knows what
the heck is going on right we're making
progress on that but if there was a
single source of truth where any one say
in a team or in an organization could
almost like an API link to and pull a
piece of knowledge a piece of content on
demand as needed in a format using an
interface that they could that they knew
was predictable that they knew they
could rely on simultaneous development
right we could break out these heavy
lifts into smaller pieces which would
improve collaboration it would improve
remote work right if you could just send
one module out to a developer around the
world get it back and with having a
clean interface know how that was going
to be integrated back into your work all
of this happens today but it's very very
messy right very messy and a focus on
incremental changes I love the what I've
been reading on the virtual DOM and tree
reconciliation how
you don't have to refresh every time and
how often is knowledge work like that
right a new hire joins the company you
have to teach them everything like take
your time sit with them to educate them
from 0 to 100 right and then another
person comes online you're oh we're
always starting from nothing for some
reason and knowledge work and knowledge
work doesn't have to be that way it
could be reusable because it's just
information it's just knowledge and
leaking linking this back to flow this
isn't just about more productivity right
it's not just about let's get more work
done with even fewer people right
there's actually something about the
fundamental experience of work here okay
because if you look at the three
internal triggers for flow the ones that
we have control over they all become
much easier when work is broken down
into packets right it's much easier to
make a clear goal for one little module
that you're creating rather than a
massive project right it's much easier
to get immediate feedback on one little
module one document one analysis one
presentation whatever it is than to wait
weeks or months for it to go to the
market and get feedback and it's much
easier to calibrate exactly how hard
something should be for one little
module than a massive project okay I
think that software developers probably
experience have access to flow more than
maybe any other profession right because
you have these things okay but flow
today I think is a privilege it's a rare
privilege for hyper educated and hyper
specialized knowledge workers like us
right imagine if that experience was
more common if more people all around
the world lawyers accountants doctors
analysts personal assistants everyone
was able to not force themselves into a
way of working that involved a
heavy-lift but was able to structure
their work to produce the psychological
effects that they're interested in
so this is the the problem that I'm
focused on right now which is called
which I call personal knowledge
management you probably never heard of
personal knowledge management you can
check out the Wikipedia article but I
imagine a future where we are not just
knowledge workers you know like they're
on the production line like working our
knowledge okay new product working our
knowledge
we're actually knowledge managers so we
take a couple steps back from the
production line we're like the foreman
up on the catwalk looking down on his
knowledge workers and the knowledge
workers would be systems would be
technological systems would be the
different sort of like organizational
systems that I'm talking about here we
can gain more leverage more speed and
more throughput from the tools at our
disposal which as we're learning here
are getting more and more advanced every
year so I'm here because I need a help
okay I can read some articles and you
know do some little tutorials and listen
to talks but as you could probably tell
I don't have the real world experience
to make the mappings between what's
going on in software and what's going on
in other types of work so if you're
interested in this or you'd like to
learn more or you think there's
something I missed you have some
feedback for me I'd really really love
for you to reach out to me this site is
not live yet but by the end of the
conference it will be it'll have these
slides with my commentary right once I
have the recording of this talk I'll
post the video as well it's going to
have it's almost finished a blog post on
sort of what would the next stage be
like like if we had modular knowledge
work how we would actually complete
projects and I have my contact
information which is also here really
encourage you to come talk to me come
find me join me during my AMA at four
o'clock and otherwise find me online or
on Twitter thank you